if you pay attention to the things that
shine forth because what you're seeing
is the reality instead of the map you're
gaining access to the real information
that's in the world it's not prepackaged
information begin because that can be
false it's the real information flowing
out from the ground of being and if you
pay attention to that it will help you
move towards the goals that you've
already established for yourself as a
good citizen that are part of the
inbuilt value structure that you've
adopted but at the same time it will do
something else it will lead you to
transform the nature of those goals
because as you pursue the thing that
guides your interest and more and more
information is revealed then by
absorbing that information which is
learning essentially you build yourself
into a different person a stronger and
more informed person and a more a more
intact person a person with more
integrity and with more strength than
with more direction and at the same time
you differentiate your map and so you're
living more and more in the real world
so as you approach your specific goal
even if it's a culturally conditioned
goal the learning that you do along the
way transforms you and it transforms the
nature of your goal
you